welcome back to the David Pakman show
I'm fair and cousins from Ring of Fire
sitting in for David today David's at a
media cryptocurrency event in South
Florida but he will be back tomorrow
interesting development this week in the
love life of Donald Trump or should I
say the sexual misconduct claims against
Donald Trump um a woman has come forward
The Washington Post did a whole profile
on her
Rachel crooks she's actually running for
office this year and she described an
incident that she says took place
between her and Donald Trump in an area
of Trump Tower where Trump came up
grabbed her and kissed her and in
according to trump the lobby she says it
was more over in kind of a side area
near a different office and so when
these revelations came about Donald
Trump did what he does best he got on
Twitter trying to deny it and make the
story completely go away he said a woman
I don't know and to the best of my
knowledge never met is on the front page
of the fake news watch to post saying I
kissed her for two minutes yet in the
lobby of Trump Tower 12 years ago never
happened
Donald Trump says that his denial
completely vindicates him but here's the
interesting thing and this is where the
story starts to get a little weird Trump
himself
has already twisted and fabricated parts
of Rachel crooks his story she never
said it was in the lobby of Trump Tower
you know and Trump goes on to say that
there's security cameras everywhere and
they totally tell the story of me not
actually doing this this horrible thing
and sexually assaulting this woman in my
building okay
as Rachel crook says let's see the tapes
if you're certain they'll vindicate you
why won't you just release them to the
public and you have to assume at this
point that there's a very good reason
why they won't be released to the public
because they don't vindicate Donald
Trump where the evidence has been
destroyed or because maybe it shows
something even worse than that but if
Donald Trump was really being honest
here and he
video evidence showing that he did
absolutely nothing wrong and that Rachel
crooks was a liar don't you think we
would have seen it at this point and
that's what gets me about everything
that Donald Trump has said he always
goes out there denies every single thing
that's ever happened and yet has never
been able to produce a single bit of
evidence to convince us that he's
telling the truth and that the women are
lying doesn't that seem a little
interesting furthermore why is it that
anybody always or everybody most people
in this country have to give the benefit
of the doubt to the guy we always assume
that the women are just lying about this
Rachel crooks along with the other 20
women who have come forward they do not
have anything to gain from this you know
this isn't a bragging right they're not
trying to just drain Donald Trump of
finances or be famous nobody wants to be
famous for being a woman that Donald
Trump groped in a hotel that's not what
this is about this is about exposing the
disgusting behavior of the sitting
president of the United States and in
this particular story I'm gonna err on
the side of caution and believe what
mrs. crooks is telling us rather than
what Donald Trump is telling us you know
why because by his own admission he
likes to do the things that Miss crooks
has accused him of doing
remember the tape where he said I don't
even wait I grabbed them and I kissed
them and they they let you do it when
you're rich and powerful
sounds like a an admission to me so why
would we take his word over Miss crooks
and to be honest I don't think we should